what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back with another installment of our
beyond omega level series where we break
down the most powerful characters in all
of comic books and i feel like we should
kind of start deviating away from like
marvel and dc a little bit and start
focusing on non-marvel and dc characters
but regardless in this video we're
focusing on a character you guys have
requested a lot the demon trigger so
trigon was created by marv wolfman and
george perez and made his first
appearance in the new teen titans number
four in 1981. now trigon is an ancient
demonic entity born out of the union
between a cult and the deity they
worship which resulted in all of the
evil energy of that dimension known as
azerath becoming personified in trigon
now trigan wastes no time in showing off
his potential for destruction as soon as
he's born this guy kills everybody in
the vicinity including his own mother
and for his first birthday he has
basically taken over an entire planet
and by age of six he was able to destroy
a planet so honestly we could end the
video there because he's basically
proven to be omega level by the age of
six thanks for watching guys peace
in all seriousness though dragon's
ultimate ambition is to basically
enslave the entirety of every reality
and by the age of 30 he'd conquered his
entire dimension which consisted of
millions of worlds now to give you guys
better perspective trigon has been
around for thousands of years and is
basically the embodiment of evil within
the dc universe which has brought him
into conflicts with several superheroes
but most of his battles have been with
the teen titans because he's also the
father of one of its members raven and
that brings us to a point that we have
to address before we go any further and
that's yes trigon routinely loses to a
group of teenagers and while that is
admittedly funny it doesn't take away at
all from how powerful trigon is because
at the end of the day that's just how
comics work bad guys are shown to be
ridiculously powerful to make it seem
like the heroes have no chance of
defeating them because they're way
overpowered but at the end of the day
the heroes find a way to win because
they're the good guys but even then a
demonic entity who conquered an entire
dimension filled with millions of worlds
lost to teenagers but with that out of
the way we can get into trigon's powers
which are so immense that they basically
encompass everything and what i mean by
that is since trigon is the
personification of evil he's made of
evil energy and therefore has vast
demonic powers that he can use in
practically any way he wishes not
surprisingly trigon has superhuman
strength speed and durability but that
barely scratches the surface of what
trigon is capable of i mean barely
scratches the surface right this guy
also possesses omniscience meaning that
he knows everything that can be known as
well as precognition meaning that he
also knows what will occur before it
happens he's also a powerful telekinetic
and when i say powerful i don't mean
that he can just move some really heavy
stuff with his mind i mean that he can
literally use his telekinesis to alter
space and time as well as manipulate
matter trigen is also a powerful magic
wielder and can warp reality with only a
thought he can destroy matter on a
subatomic level which defies the laws of
physics and was able to turn every
person on earth to stone which requires
a great proficiency in matter
manipulation not only is he able to
destroy and transform matter but he's
also able to create something from
nothing which is even more evidence that
the natural laws of the universe simply
don't apply to him trigon can also
teleport interdimensionally and is even
able to break down dimensional barriers
he can also channel his mystic energy
into beams called a death stare that's
powerful enough to destroy planets and
during a battle with the teen titans
dragon brags about destroying galaxies
and universes which would place him well
beyond omega level and furthermore the
monitor states that dragon's power level
is in the same ballpark as the spectres
which would make him one of the most
powerful entities in the dc universe and
the most powerful entity in the dc
universe to basically lose to teenagers
now like nearly every character in dc
dragon's origin was altered by the new
52 reboot this version of trigon was
born eons ago in a different universe
where three entities known as the divine
were trying to rid their universe of
evil to accomplish this they used the
heart of darkness a planet-sized object
that siphoned evil out of everything it
touches and when they discover that a
world they'd already purged of evil had
once again been consumed with evil they
return and one of them reveals himself
to basically be trigon who absorbs the
heart of darkness which contains all of
the evil from the universes it had also
drained and so this version of trigan is
pretty much the embodiment of evil just
like the pre-flashpoint version was and
so after absorbing the heart of darkness
trigen sets out across multiple
universes looking for more evil to
devour and dragon conquers multiple
worlds turning each of them into hellish
versions of themselves and his plan is
to basically leave a son behind on each
to rule in his place however only three
of these sons survive and he doesn't
view any of them as a worthy successor
eventually one of his minions brings him
a woman from earth and they have a
daughter who of course would be raven of
the teen titans and after seeing how
powerful she is he decides that earth
women are suitable mothers for the army
of children that he wants in order to
help him rule the universe and much like
the pre-flash point version of trigon
the new 52 version is extremely powerful
even before absorbing the heart of
darkness when he was one of the three
divine he ruled over a dozen dimensions
and became even more powerful after
absorbing the heart which contained the
evil of almost a thousand galaxies
trigen is then able to slay the other
two members of the divine before
conquering countless planets galaxies
and universes now he's also confronted
by the phantom stranger most of you guys
know him as an entity that is himself
way beyond omega level who had been sent
by the voice which is basically dc's
version of god and trigon is defiantly
confident in his ability to stand up to
either of them now try again also has a
variety of other powers like flight
shape-shifting the ability to grow to
extreme heights mind control spitting
hellfire and he also has total control
over an entire army of demons now he's
also effectively immortal having existed
for thousands of years so yeah trigon is
definitely a character that is beyond
omega level and i think he's often
overlooked because his primary
adversaries are kids who are not
typically viewed as being really
powerful at all outside of raven none of
them are really viewed as powerful
especially when compared to the justice
league but trigon should definitely
never be underestimated and he's
certainly one of the most powerful
forces of evil in the dc universe and is
definitely deserving of a spot on our
list of beyond omega level characters
but with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this to an end as always
leave your comments down below let me
know who else you're interested in
seeing thank you all for watching and i
will catch you guys later
peace